but you recently had to deal with your
own bullies right online yeah I had a
nude photo leaked like how nude what are
we talking my hair well first of all let
me just tell you something it wasn't
that bad first of all if I had your body
I was actually way more embarrassed
about all the screen grabs of
inspirational quotes that I had of my
father no it's actually my own fault I
was doing Instagram stories one night
and I weed is now legal in California
which is not a good mix don't clap for
that and so I had done and it kind of
slipped a little and I posted it by
accident and then a bunch of people were
like oh my god your boob is on Instagram
and I was and then I deleted it so they
had just done a screengrab and then
later they said like how much money to
for us to not post this and I was like
I'm not giving you my money I've worked
too hard and my boob looks great and you
know what I paid good money for these
[Applause]
nude photos of me I mean it's doubt I'm
in the bathtub I look like I'm having a
home birth like it's not like in a tub
of water so it's not you're high so
you're thinking I look awesome the best
anyone's ever seen me holding a sponge
it's very odd but that's awesome as
smart of you see you you ended up
putting it out cuz you were like you
want to get in the money but I just
getting paid for my boob it's yummy me
yeah okay so I just you know what I just
took the bargaining chip off the table
it's the only thing I knew how to do so
I was just like if you're I'm just gonna
post it myself it's amazing see it's a
boob is it yeah I'm like you can see
that sometimes at restaurants when
people are nursing it's a boob yeah it's
fine I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this